So here are the quantities
that make up a POMDP.
We have a set of quantities
that are actually just an MDP.
There's a set of actions and
states and transitions and rewards.
But the thing is that that
MDP that is inside the POMDP
isn't directly observable to the agent.
And instead,
the agent has to make its decisions
based on the observations that it makes.
So this Z stands for surveysions
>> Or observables.
>> So it's a set, like S and A.
And then we need some kind of function
that connects the states and the actions
and the observables, or actually,
just the states and the observables, and
we're going to write that as O,
which is the observation function.
What O consists of is
a mapping from state and
observation to the probability of
actually seeing that observation,
given that the agent's
currently in that state S.
>> Okay, that makes sense.
So there's a true MDP, and
what makes the MDP really,
I don't know, an MDP or,
is really the state.
The key thing has always been what state
are we in right now, and what you're
saying is that with a POMDP, you never
actually know what state you're in.
And so you get these observables or
these observations, and
that's what you see that gives you
a hint about what state you're in.
But doesn't necessarily
tell you everything, so
what's a concrete example
of that in the real world?
>> Well, in the real world, I mean,
in the real world,
the real world is like this, right?
So when I'm talking to you and
some aspects of the state of the world
in Atlanta are actually relevant and
important to me, like whether or
not you have ice cream.
But I can't directly observe that.
I have to infer the presence of ice
cream indirectly from whether or
not you're taunting me.
>> [LAUGH] But I'm always taunting you.
But I think I get your point.
Okay, that's fair, that makes sense.
>> Yeah, I mean,
you could taunt me about ice cream, and
that's not a perfect indicator
that you actually have ice cream.
>> That's true, sometimes I just
taunt you for the fun of it.
>> Exactly, so what I need is some
kind of observation function.
I need to be able to predict, given
whether or not you have ice cream, so
that's given you have ice cream,
what's the probability you taunt me?
It's very close to 1.
And given that you don't have ice cream,
what's the probability that you taunt
me, and that's much lower, but not 0.
>> But still close to 1.
[LAUGH]
>> Well,
you won't taunt me about ice cream
when you don't have ice cream so much.
>> That's true, also, when I have
ice cream, you can hear me smacking.
>> Smacking?
>> [SOUND]
>> And making mouth sounds.
Well, again,
that's a [LAUGH] kind of observation.
So smacking is a kind of observation
that, again, is indicative of, but
not a perfect indicator of, whether or
not you've got ice cream in your mouth.
>> Okay, fair enough, fair enough.
All right, so I think I get that, okay.
So, POMDP basically has an MDP inside
of it, and you can't see all of it.
And in particular,
the part you can't see is S and maybe T.
>> The T relates S and A, right?
The T says how given that you're in
a state and you take some action,
what state you go to next.
But of course, you don't really
know what state you were in.
And you may not know what
state you ended up in.
Because, again, you, as the agent,
have to make decisions
based on what you can see.
>> Okay, fair enough.
>> Great.
Now would be a good time for
a transition to the next slide,
if we knew what it was.
>> Well,
do we even know what slide we're in?
>> [LAUGH]